I'll concepción is pretty close to being
done with his review for neo yes it is a
new production yes yeah we haven't
published it yet uh we all played it in
like varying varying stunt time yes I
played it for 30 minutes yeah I played
it for a few hours and I really liked
this game so far and I was not expecting
to because it was actually kind of an
eye opener um this is sounds like a
weird tangent I know I do those a lot
but this actually has merit um in my
money in about a month is uh you still
hear me yeah in about a month is the
castlevania symphony at night 20th
anniversary 97 released that would make
it I'm doing some math right now
um and I forget what day it is in March
but uh I was looking at neo and it
reminds me of symphony night because neo
is clearly going for Dark Souls they
have in previews they've told us that's
what they're doing it's team ninja
famous for ninja gaiden it's taking
Ninja Gaiden and applying some of the
mechanics there and some of the minor
things to a Dark Soul structure in that
very hard you know fighting mechanics
you know you're gathering this
experience that you can lose when you
die death is a huge deal but it's also
kind of the norm it's necessary well I
guess not necessary if you want to go
through the game without dying but
that'd be up very hard these kind of
like interlacing worlds that are you
know very complicated and whatnot and
there are a lot of similar gonna go into
it more we're gonna talk more about how
neo compares to blood-borne
but I was wondering I was like this is
really fun but like what are the kind of
questions I get raised when you're gonna
rip rip off as a strong word but
essentially take that take a game and
almost clone it but then I was looking
at Symphony of the Night and they
essentially you know Castlevania games
are kind of riding off a Metroid's steam
right a little bit but you could also
say that about medibot
metroid was kind of once all that
metroid came out not too far apart yeah
but even Zelda is very similar she's a
different different perspective on them
and you know the saying goes like game
design is all just iteration so I was
thinking like what other I'd like to see
maybe more franchises kind of take what
makes their IPs
special like Ninja Gaiden with the very
well designed combat and those games
were difficult in their own right and
apply that to something with a structure
of a dark soldier a blood-borne like I
don't know maybe like you could figure
out a way maybe maybe you could take a
Tom Clancy game and make it like Dark
Souls bring it in check maybe the next
Splinter Cell will be like Dark Souls
for those people who are just joining
that joke won't make sense at all but uh
that would be cool
a shooter with like Dark Souls structure
I think we talked before the show about
movie equilibrium equilibrium that's it
that's how you pronounce it you
pronounce the French way equilibrium uh
the gun kata know what gun kata yeah
yeah the Grahamstown clerics Christian
Bale Taye Diggs who's from Syracuse okay
uh no Rochester some upstate New York
City I only bring this up to hear him
ramble oh that's what happened earlier
it's I was there for those who need
equilibrium not seen it's like a movie
about a society where like people aren't
allowed to have feelings and there are
enforcers and Christian Bale plays one
of these people he stops taking his
medication so he starts having feelings
it sounds like Fahrenheit 451 Art's not
allowed sure thank you not having
feelings sounds cool I like that yeah
they yeah they take a medication for it
and something let's call train these
officers in the art of gun fighting
where you learn a position for every
possible scenario that could ever happen
so you could literally walk into a room
and follow this kata so you do these
moves
no matter what everyone in the room is
gonna die and you'll be okay the famous
I think the one that comes to mind is
there's a bunch these people holding out
defending these paintings hold out I
forget what they're called they go to
the Narrows or whatever that might be
Batman I'm just getting my station
battle stuff mixed up but it Kicks down
this door the graviton cleric he Kicks
down the door slides in on the door
everybody starts shooting the lights go
out and then all of a sudden in the
brief light flash from his gun you hear
this like whooshing sound as he sweets
like and I'm not exaggerating these
movements he goes behind his head he
goes like ponder each arm sorry uh and
yeah he's got these like double desert
eagles that he's using what does that
have to do with Dark Souls
you were talking I'm talking about you
you're talking about applying
Dark Souls like combat with a game that
is some guns sure yeah yeah weapons
dances gun kata Stan I mean Christian
Bale you could also just do realistic
like death
if you're shot or you know yes and I
like that totally oh man but we also
talked about how neo compares to blood
how it's better just forget that
previous segment hey um just I feel like
more depth here um we did so neo uh Eric
Tay who is close to finish the game you
might finished it I think he came in
saying it's a lot more like blood-borne
the Dark Soul it's very much like Dark
Souls structurally it feels a little
more like blood burn blood-borne I think
it's faster paced Dark Souls 3 kind of a
little bit from blood-borne and how your
sort can be dodged oriented if you want
it to but watching the oh footage here
it looks like a ninja gaiden game in
terms of mechanics but you know it's
very difficult but it's like this
open-world RPG in open worlds kind of
disingenuous I'll get to that soon but
it's also very story oriented much more
it's not this Oh like kind of
translucent story that blood-borne told
yeah that's what I was going to bring up
is um like in Miguel's review in
progress he talked a lot about the
character not like specific the main
character but like the the charm isn't
the right word either but like the the
style of the game it sets it apart from
blood-borne and Dark Souls in that it it
has its own unique Flair um inside
Japanese folklore yeah and I that's the
part that appeals to me the most is like
the the historical aspect there's a lot
of historical figures in Neo um and so
that's the part I know that's kind of
not what you were going for cuz we're
talking about mechanics and no no the
old bags I ran down yeah yeah that's
that's the big thing that stood out to
me because that's kind of that's usually
what I focus on in games I'm super drawn
to the historical Japanese setting and
yeah this is based on uh that your
character is pretty based on um william
adams he was the first like western he
showed up in japan in like the 16th
century and he was the first as a second
western person to be a sora yes do it
and then he trained like Christian Bale
did in equilibrium um this was like what
7th 17th century 16th early 1580
something up if memory serves maybe that
were 16th century right yes okay I get
that mixed up all the time um but other
ways it's kind of similar Dark Souls and
blood-borne uh weapons stances dark
those three had the webinar and has the
trick weapons I can switch between like
you know the hammer the cur camera or
the sword that it plunges into the sword
stone each weapon in neo has three
stances high low and mid and you can see
here if you're watching the gameplay
down to bottom right it shows you the
one on the right just you're sort of
sheets but other than that is high low
and mid high is more based on damage and
attacking mid is kind of a defensive and
then low low damage but it makes easier
to dodge you're not wasting as much key
which is the stamina ki which is a huge
deal in this game even more something
the stamina in Dark Souls or blood-borne
it you first of all you can see on the
enemies you could see their stamina
underneath their health bar which is big
because if their stamina runs out and if
your stamina runs out either or you like
freeze it is much more of a penalty than
a darksouls it's much more punishing you
kind of have to recover quickly I would
say with enemies if they do it obviously
bosses and mini-bosses will have much
more ki but these enemies if they run
out you can go up and do these like
finishing attacks and then you also you
know can kind of manage yours by doing
these key pulses if you see a stamina
bar here in the gameplay when it drains
there's this blue segment really quick
up [ __ ] with issues the the guardian
spirit attack which I'll get into but
you have this brief second to refill the
key you just used if you press r1 like
right after you attack at the right time
which miguel concepción who played
through this game said he I don't think
he used it much or he was just saying
you don't have to use it you don't you
can get through the game without it you
can just back up and if the enemy is not
fast enough it'll recharge but it
recharges much faster if you do this the
cool thing is if you do it there's
certain parts where you get into like
these yokai realms and if you do that
once like perfectly it gets out without
you having to beat the enemy or it'll
like push those yokai away
the yokai being these like a yoke above
the Genesis ghosts yeah um and then the
weapons stances come into play when
you're fighting other samurai and more
skill-based enemies because you can
recognize their weapon stance and know
what they're going for and know how best
to counter that if they're in a high
weapon stance you might want to go low
because you know they're going for
damage and slower attacks whereas you
could just dodge around and whittle away
their health and like Miguel had said
numerous times the office in his review
in progress is that there's a really
cool visual style to this game or like a
visual vocabulary
that lets you know what the enemies are
going to do more so than just they're
going to Telegraph the attack when they
start to wind up yes but you can also
see what stands there and that's going
to like you know effect and kind of
encourage you to use a certain stance of
your own and let you read these
situations before the monster actually
attacks we want to see their their
stamina as well super helpful and a
little bit I played today it was like
that automatically made the game more
accessible for me because I knew I was
on injures and information on even
footing with my opponent okay yeah I did
want to touch on accessibility cuz you
brought it up before we started
recording or shooting filming whatever
the word is live streaming streaming
there we go um I I know things just um I
think the other other thing that
appealed to me is because I'm very
intimidated by the difficult difficulty
of souls like games but I Miguel said
this and then other reviewers also that
I read we're talking about how co-op
that doesn't likes enemies don't scale
when you do co-op so you can get through
a particularly tough area and like oh
it's like a 15 minute like walking
phone-a-friend yeah I walk in the park
so like a crisis right yeah I do like
that you can lean on that like you're
getting really frustrated I I am I could
I can do a good rage quit so I I'm happy
to know that that's available to me um
which also makes it less intimidating to
start playing and then the tutorials at
the beginning and the information that
you get adds to that like okay starting
this is not going to be this huge
endeavor I don't feel like I have to
take a class to learn how to play this
game I don't have to study it as much
and then that comes later naturally as
you're playing another thing in terms of
you mentioned co-op multiplayer ish area
in Dark Souls you have people that can
invade your game this has the revenant
system so you come up on what look like
bonfires and Dark Souls or the sword
stuck in the ground it's red glowing
thing and when you go near it it shows
where another player died but it also
shows you what they had equipped so if
you see that they had really good
equipment obviously you want to get it
because you in this game you find much
more loot than Dark Souls you're not
sticking to one weapon that you're
upgrading yeah I felt like your weapons
and by the [ __ ]
yeah finding the same samurai sword just
with better stats you're not finding
again the Kirk Cameron just updating
that with blood gems throughout your
you're finding loot a lot and it's
really cool risk/reward it's like the
epitome of risk reward you see that they
have like really good equipment which
obviously means are gonna be harder to
fight though so it's always if you want
to get that equipment they have its if
it's worth fighting it's almost always
going to be your outgunned which is cool
and but you don't have to some of them
that's the revenant system and that's
like how it's a little bit different
from blood-borne Dark Souls as well
which I actually really like this
because it's a loot based game so this
kind of encourages you to go for the
better loot by getting to these more
difficult fights Guardian spirits are a
big deal you can pick one that boost
your stats there's also a skill tree for
this guardian spirit so you can upgrade
them to upgrade your your heart body
skill dexterity
I love stats right yeah and then right
now my guardian spirit that I'm using is
like some sort of bird dragon that
swoops down hits people and then it
buffs your weapon and you can just hit
in wider attacks and more difficult
attacks and there's like special
abilities you get there's you can
upgrade your samurai abilities by using
getting proficiency with samurai weapons
you can upgrade ninjutsu abilities by
using ninja weapons and you go into a
skill tree of their own this game is
much more I think in terms of the
weapons in the combat as much more
in-depth and blood-borne and Dark Souls
actually which those games have
fantastic he's saving much more or just
like more customizations okay
there's more customization involved with
your skill trees you can have two
samurai abilities you can have you know
three weapon stances as opposed to the
two you can have you get more weapons
and then the beginning you pick like two
weapons you want to be proficient with I
picked the regular samurai sword than an
axe
I thought they balanced each other out
well and then for another difference you
can Dark Soul have always kind of been
these open world-ish things that are
intersecting in weird ways and then you
can start warping between bonfires as
the game goes on you discover more areas
this game I brought up earlier it's like
a Mario map when you go to the when
you're actually going the overworld this
in places you pick and then once you
clear these areas or maybe not clear
because it's like if you go back to a
shrine the shrines are just like
bonfires and Dark Souls enemies will
regenerate so you can go back and you
know farm them for emerita if you want
which is like the souls the upgrade
currency in this game
you once you clear Nair you can go back
into a Twilight Mission version which is
just that's it's like a Carter sure it's
like a Persian right it's yeah the
enemies are harder but the loots better
so it's encouraging you to retread if
you want better loot because say you
can't even go to the vanilla version
this new area when without better loot
have you done much of that no because my
my question there is like does that get
to grindy or is it necessary to go back
and try to get better loot or can you
kind of get what you need along the way
like that's my remaining question from
what I've heard it can me I don't know
if it can be grindy but it gets really
hard
I would assume maybe with her damning
some yeah grinding is always relative to
the amount of effort you have to put
forth right expecially an RPG grinding
for me associated with just doing rote
thing yes so far my experience is you
cannot just act in a rote manner and
when facing enemies in this game so yeah
maybe it's satisfying even if it is
repetitive yeah like you're doing the
same thing but you actually pay
attention to what you're doing that's
less I mean it doesn't have the negative
connotations of repetition sure you know
what I mean
yeah filleted are on the twitch chat was
calling up my uh Mario comparison how
else is this game like Mario how else
hmm its star questions a white man in
Japan that isn't that is accurate
oh it's Mario in Japan is the modern
game is Han dinosaur
no no well he's in New York in the
upcoming Mario Odyssey yeah yeah maybe
you want to Japan but I tried I didn't
really set anybody up for success with
that one uh but yes by and large you
know it's kind of low hanging fruit to
talk about how a neo compares to
blood-borne Dark Souls but it is it's
they've been open with the fact that
they're trying to do their own version
of that and I think from what I played
and from what I've heard it's something
succeeded yeah it was really fun so far
and I hooks in me I have the game pot
well you can't pause the game but I have
like the PlayStation menu up my desk
right now I hope that pauses it I was
otherwise I'm dead right now I was
always intrigued by how much it reminded
me of Onimusha just on a superficial
level yeah but then like the opening
cutscene is almost to the opening
cutscene from the original Onimusha like
the first thing you see is a crow
picking it flesh which is like right
there then you see an army and fit yeah
and so there's a lot of if you like
Onimusha as well yeah maybe
is your chance I remember his answers
ninja gaiden 3 was it the last one I
played that's hard as [ __ ] yes
this game is hard for different ways but
can kill you fast um cool I think that's
it yeah go play neo our review will be
up later on this some point this week
soon soon soon very soon so keep an eye
on gamespot for a new review from Miguel
concepción we're cutting the video
review today try to get ready as soon as
possible and yeah from us 3 here the
table it's it's got us really interested
and I really like the game so far so go
check it out from team ninja cool and
then also let us know your own thoughts
if you've got the chance to play it
since yesterday released I'm like my
Hardy on Twitter or Emma Hardy or mmm a
hardy Catholic lag you don't know you
are people think I'm an anime fighter
all the time ok I'm a inky Doge eco i
and k yd o ji k keeo or just search
Kelly plague if you and then Peter Brown
PCB Brown PP Brown PC Brown PC Brown
yeah
nice I'm gonna change my halo soon fine
I like it that's good ok
anyway thank you all so much for ya
leaving your thoughts in the chat and
like I said has up on Twitter if you
have any more thoughts on neo if you get
the chance to play it
[Music]